the best way
to create jobs and opportunity the best
way to inspire innovation inspired
growth
is by supporting small businesses right
uh small businesses employ more than
anyone else in the world most of the
world's economic activity flows through
small businesses and it's really hard to
run a small business right you are kind
of on your own this is really the
genesis of main street came and came up
it's like we know we wanted to help
uh you know support these businesses
create you know create jobs create
opportunity for people
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community community-driven vc fund in
silicon valley in partnership with
lumitec sponsored by homeward ventures
hippo insurance oppos labs synergy
global hillel at stanford leap
birthright excel server partners and in
media partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders welcome doug ludlow ceo of main
street a company that helps small
businesses and startups claim tax
credits most accountants never claim
before main street he served as chief of
staff for google's smb and nbu ads was
founder of hipster acquired by aol in
2012 and happy home acquired by google
in 2016.
doug has a bachelor's of arts in history
and political science from the
university of california los angeles and
currently lives in san jose with his
wife sarah and two children charlotte
and william
doug ludlow welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me today
how are you
i'm great i'm super happy to be here
super excited i'm really excited to have
you here with me and talking about
something that i know very very little
about which is you know taxes and
government and compliance i i do need to
understand it better but but i do
understand a little bit about startups
and a little bit about how you know the
the amount of money that you're able to
save for over a thousand companies
you've worked with so far how that is
meaningful especially to a young startup
in their early stages and so i i can
definitely understand the pain point
that you're solving though i'm really
curious how you got there but we'll get
there in a second doug tell me a little
bit about yourself you've done some some
really really interesting things from
being an innovation partner at aol
ventures a ceo and co-founder of the
happy home company working within google
as chief of staff to smb ads and now as
the ceo of main street how do you define
you know your career trajectory looking
back
yeah that's a great question i
i don't know if i've had a career
trajectory i think i've been
lucky to do work with great people
at both startups and big companies so
like this is my third company i had a
first company called hipster that was
like an early instagram competitor i
you know acquired by aol a million years
ago then worked at aol for a while
started a new company this was called
happy home it was like a personal home
manager this company was not successful
but we were i guess as the term goes
aqua hired by google to build the google
home services ad unit and then yeah
spent a little over three and a half
years at google as most of my time as
chief of staff for all small business
ads so it's been a
i think i've seen a lot of the
technology industry like from very very
very early stage startups to
you know i was helping run a 17 billion
dollar ads portfolio within google right
so it's uh
i've kind of seen the entire spectrum
and uh it's been a fun journey
wow and incredible and you know what
what motivated you throughout the
journey what what motivated you
to be a serial entrepreneur and start
these companies and then stick within
those larger companies and and see the
technology and and the emerging
technologies from in-house what was sort
of the the driving force for you
yeah i mean a couple reasons one i mean
it's fun right if you've been an
entrepreneur you know this is
there's very little that compares to the
rush of
you know
putting together a team building
something new
giving your you know giving your best
shot i
mean for someone like me it's a ton of
fun for some people other people i'm
sure would be a
horrible stressful terrible experience
but i love it i
and and secondly
you know i
i don't know how long i'll live on this
earth right i don't know how much time i
have in life right wouldn't you rather
spend your time doing something that was
exciting and interesting that you know
you thought was worthy of your time and
so that's one of the great things about
startups right is that i think you are
spending your time pouring yourself into
something that matters uh and something
that you get to create and can't think
of a better way to spend uh at least the
the time i go into my career i'm doing
you know the startup world i love it so
let's focus on main street for now and
share with me how you came about to
understand the pain point that you're
solving today what what what experience
led to this aha moment particularly for
you
sure so
i've actually been working with small
businesses one way or the other for
about eight years first my company happy
home we were dealing with a lot of home
service providers like plumbers and
electricians
uh google then of course was working
with uh you know the 15 million not all
at once of course but the 15 million
small businesses within the google ads
platform and you start to understand
these these things that
small businesses are actually pretty
sophisticated uh they're they're
hardworking
but they just don't have time they don't
have the the bandwidth to manage
uh really anything and so like there's
like
a lot of people making it when they're
building for small businesses a lot of
companies make the mistake of thinking
that
small businesses are just like
enterprise kind of shrunk down
it's entirely not true one of the things
that you learn over time is that small
business acts much more like consumer
based products right because you're a
you know
the you're running a three-person
company like it's far more akin to a
consumer product so i i spent most of
our past decade working on small
businesses
and
you know with that background in mind
spent you know a lot of time getting to
know some of my friends at google i we
just had to start a company together and
we didn't know what we really wanted to
do at the time we knew we wanted to work
together i
but we wanted to focus on a problem we
cared about right and
the the real impetus for for main street
was we saw
a growing inequality an inequality of
jobs of opportunity of wealth of
education that was emerging let's say
most primarily most visibly let's say
between an area like san francisco and
new york
a lot of the rest of the country like
suburban and rural communities i grew up
in a place in the middle of california
central valley
that
you know the economy has just slowly
been chipped away over the last 40 years
right it's really hard to get a job out
of high school it's really hard to run a
small business and so i saw the effect
on my community of what happens when
there are no good jobs what happens when
opportunity dries up
and you know me and my co-founders dan
lindquist and dana griffin that we
wanted to help solve this we wanted to
help you know combat this inequality i
and given our backgrounds we all work
together the google small business team
without the best way
to create jobs and opportunity the best
way to inspire innovation inspired
growth
is by supporting small businesses right
small businesses employ more than anyone
else in the world most of the world's
economic activity flows through small
businesses and it's really hard to run a
small business right you are kind of on
your own this is really the genesis of
main street came and came up it's like
we know we wanted to help
uh you know support these businesses
create you know create jobs create
opportunity for people
and we knew that you know these people
were on their own they needed help
especially when it came to their
finances and so starting to develop
these things like on one hand you have
people who need a lot of help who are
smart who are trying to build something
on the other hand you have all these
almost hidden pools of money and support
that people can tap into government tax
credits was the first we we moved into
uh we're now looking at like we looked
at enterprise discounts right the same
type of like discounts that google would
get for example to buy software we're
passing on to
a small guy we're now moving to like you
know actually some web 3 stuff
right how do you you know small business
most part
many people don't have any idea how you
access high-yield accounts through you
know their web three products we want to
make it easy so you can think of this
like
this isn't like uh
we call ourselves a smart bank right we
sit on your finances uh we understand
your business and then you find all the
areas that you can make or save money in
a really easy seamless way so
i i know i just gave you the roundabout
story there but that's that's how it
started us with our goals so for the
traditional company to be helping get
get some money in return and
you know first
how does it work i mean what are the
different use cases that are non-trivial
in which
companies may be able to earn some of
the money
back
through main street
sure i'll give three different
like key
ways people do this one are tax credits
right i
from the government right there's
there's
literally hundreds of billions of
dollars with the tax credits that go
unused uh because people don't know they
exist so what mainstream does is after
you sign up you plug in your core
business systems we analyze what's going
on uh at your business and then we help
match you with government credits help
apply and you either get a check from
the government or you get the you know
use user credit against your payroll tax
like again it's really seamless it takes
you know the thing you would spend a ton
of money on with an accountant or a
totally trying to do it yourself and
makes it a 20-30 minute process
another way is like again we're we're
connected all your core business systems
including your accounting system we know
what you're spending your money on we
help you automatically save money on
your your your spend your expenses right
we know you're spending this much on
slack we know you're spending this much
on you know error table interest you
know on your sales price on lawyers etc
we help automatically identify savings
there right again very little work and
the savings can be hundreds of thousands
of dollars for companies that are
growing and finally again we're
connected to all your systems so we know
that most of your money as a startup or
small business sits in a zero percent
interest checking account or you know at
silicon valley bank or a chase we can
help move some of that into some high
yield accounts again very little time so
it's the the magic happens when someone
joins mainstream connects you know their
accounting systems their hr systems we
then use our matching engine that we
develop to you know pull that data and
intelligently suggest
uh you know what you should do to make
and save more money it's why we call
ourselves a smart bank right all right
we intelligently help you you know know
where you should put your money what you
should do with it so are people today
doing this just on their own and then
hopefully if you have an accountant or
if you have a cfo then they'd be able to
go and and make these you know
capture these opportunities or you know
what what is really the pain point that
the mainstream is solving is it more of
the the observability layer or is it
more of the scale layer of being able to
identify you know all the opportunities
that there are
well step one is the discoverability
problem right i
and if you're if you're running a
restaurant or a startup or a law firm
you're focused on your customers you're
focused on you know getting that meal
out the door getting that product
shipped etc you're not thinking you
don't you don't even know to look for
savings you don't even know that these
things exist right i
you know this is my third company this
is the first time i've learned about tax
credits this is the first time i've
learned about that i can i don't have to
spend off the shelf on software right
i can get a better return all right so
one is just discoverability like when we
make it very easy to like you know hey
here's all these opportunities second is
complexity right you can try to do it on
your own you can try to do tax credits
you can try to get negotiate like you
can try and negotiate savings etc i
and you can it's not necessarily rocket
science it just takes in some cases
dozens of hours to do so and you know
are you going to spend the time as an
entrepreneur learning
how to do this yourself
whether you might get it wrong no you're
not like you're just not going to do it
right so we handle the complexity we
take care of that for you and finally
cost i
for a lot of these services especially
like let's say an accountant or
consultant et cetera i they will charge
you an upfront fee whether they get you
a credit or money back or not right uh
us we that's not how our our business
works it's we have a we're completely
aligned with customers to where you only
pay for getting you money back so it's a
completely risk-free uh model for
companies
interesting and so if you're
looking at the
you know the greater vision of main and
where you're heading
you know what where's the what is the
big play here what is the sort of the
gold mine that you're after
you know whether it's a position in the
market or changing some consumer
behavior or changing some inequality
where what's that vision
that's a great question so
we think
that small business finance and small
business like financial world
has been
utterly broken for 20 30 years right i
it used to be that you know small
businesses would go to their local bank
and you know get all the financial tools
they need from their their local bank uh
you know whether it's actually they
collect insurance through their bank
they you know you get their loans they
get cards they get discounts like it
really was like bank of america let's
say used to be for the the average
business kind of a supermarket for
financial services well i
as banks got bigger and bigger
uh they devoted less and less time to
small businesses all right they still
make hundreds of billions of dollars
from small businesses but it's still
the small
is actually the smallest percentage of
revenue that banks make from small
businesses they make far more commercial
business banking and big business so
they kind of forgot about small business
well then the great thing that happened
over the last 10 years is this this
explosion in fintech tortoises down
hundreds of companies that all are
taking a slice
of helping a small business which is
great like we have a lot of good friends
who are running uh you know interesting
companies like pipe and cap chase and
ramp and
vendor and vouch and these are great
companies i all connected to the
financial stack of the company uh the is
as a small business owner
i don't have time to manage you know 10
20 30 different you know software
products i just don't i so we think just
like there's been an unbundling of
fintech we think there's going to be a
re a consolidation a rebundling where
hey you're a small business you want you
know one business to kind of run your
entire as we'd say the startup world
fintech stack as you know mckinsey and
wells fargo would say your beyond
banking ecosystem right
basically everything you do with your
your finances in one location that's
where we want to be we'd like to we
think our competitors are
uh or long-term or companies like
american express and bank of america
these giant financial companies that in
theory help small businesses uh with
their finances but you just kind of give
them the the
a really poor experience so that that's
our long-term vision
that's an awesome vision it's an and i
love how you're you know also outlining
your vision in terms of you know these
are these are the players that we might
be competing with today these are the
players we want to be competing with in
the future
yes and and i think that's just very
cool if you're looking yourself a little
bit and
third company that you're starting but
but
spend more time in others as well
what are you taking with you on on a
leadership level as a serial
entrepreneur that
you know may not be trivial for a first
timer or even a second timer
so i think
this is gonna sound harsh for startup
founders
i don't think you learn much as a
startup founder or it's very very very
hard to you learn a lot of experiences
to be true to be fair like you're kind
of it's an experience not like anything
else
but some of these hard skills like
finance or management i you don't really
have time to figure out how to do those
things as startup founders so actually
some of the best training i got
i wasn't a big company right was it
whether you know google primarily
i
the the difference between my ability as
a leader uh i've always been i had a
product mind i've always wanted to ship
new products uh but watching people
learn how to scale watching people learn
how to manage properly right that was
something that is
completely up my game
at main street from my previous
companies
so i would actually advise so if you
want to start a company like go work for
that you know startup workout yc company
could try to get into yc but then don't
spend your entire
early career working there go work at
google go work at facebook
learn
how the big companies do it like you
don't work for a big giant old slow
company work for like i mean facebook
and google and amazon like these guys
are competitive like they're they're
they're at the top of the game so go
work for them and then you'll have uh
kind of the best of both worlds i think
that's what i've been able to pick up at
main street like the the young scrappy
hungry company along with the
you know here you actually want to grow
to a skilled giant company
with the best practices of a company
like google but with the scrappiness and
with the young mentality of the young
companies i think that what you're
outlining here is this beautiful and
delicate balance between the two things
right
exactly i love it going back to
you again and you know looking back
before
before you're an entrepreneur and before
you're in the tech scene at all as a kid
what are you curious about what what are
the things that you're observing that
are you know making you really excited
and curious about the world
sure i well for one i've always been
kind of an entrepreneur like i had a
little uh
lawn mowing service in my neighborhood
we
made candy and sold it was a paper boi i
so always been interested in that i
think
which is which you know said something
about me i'm not sure what that is i
i do i'm actually deeply interested in
have been in politics and public service
like
understanding like how do you make i
mean growing up in a place like modesto
which was
you know like a really great place to
live in the 50s and 60s and then the
economy started hitting and you'd watch
like gangs on the street and drug deals
and like not you know it became the car
theft capital of the world right growing
up that environment watching go from one
thing like i started caring along about
you know just politics in the world and
i actually don't think in the tech world
we pay enough attention to the power of
politics right the power of government
right it's this massive force it's this
massive thing that we're able that it
controls much of what we do
and i
you know i think we
we we're probably way too disengaged as
a tech community in the political world
given just how much influences have as
well so that's a you know i mean and
that's in addition to all like the
normal video game and science stuff you
know as a kid in sports right
i was a normal kid not just worrying
about politics and
you know startups from an early age no
no i love it and i have to ask
about you and your co-founders with dan
and daniel and
santa cruz beach boardwalk chili
cook-off
what is exactly and how do you
what is that
so i for those who don't know santa cruz
you know santa cruz is the beach town
not too far from san jose palo alto and
they have this boardwalk that's like
this you know 120 year old
amusement park and you know every year
they do one giant chili cook-off and one
giant clam chowder cook-off often you
know dozens or hundreds of teams come by
and you cook
clam chowder or chili and the general
public gets it and it's judged and it's
a giant like it's a charitable event i
but yeah we my my friends and i we have
been doing the clan chowder cook-off for
eight years and the chili cook-off for
like five
and dan daniel and i for a couple of
years in a row like
won the chili cook-off wow
50 gallons of chili on the beach which
is
high which is a lot so though it was a
talk about a great team
for us so you're literally standing
there along with dozens of other teams
all of you cooking chili and then the
public comes tries it and they and then
the judges declare a winner
that's exactly right i can just picture
in my mind and i want i want to come and
visit the chili cook-off next year so so
i'm going to make sure to look to make a
note to look that up right afterwards
doug i really want to thank you i think
the work that you're doing obviously
with main street and the motivation
leading up to main street i think is is
extremely you know remarkable and
very very inspiring for me as a young
entrepreneur and the intentionality with
which you started main street with the
previous understanding and experience
from the two companies you've founded
but then also the two larger companies
that you've also worked at and sort of
bringing the scrappiness and the best
practices and obviously making a huge
impact already on on more than a
thousand companies i think that's just
really really cool and i'm sure that
every time that those companies are
saying they you know the returns that
they got from working with you it's that
that aha moment that sort of knocks on
the head i think that's just i can only
imagine how cool that is so thank you
very very much and stay safe and stay
healthy
hey youtube thanks for having me thank
you